[Music]
i'm here with megan malawi and stephanie
hunt of nancy and beth that was
fantastic thank you very much and first
of all uh megan you're on the show
children's hospital you guys just won an
emmy so congratulations
you two your voice i went and saw your
show i would say about two months ago i
went my wife and i went to see your show
and we were just blown away the two of
you have magical voices that work so
well together how would the two of you
even find each other to make to realize
you could do this we did a little indie
movie called somebody up there likes me
in austin last summer and um stephanie
mentioned that she played the ukulele
and wrote songs and so on my last day um
i was gonna very glamorous life i was
going to drive from austin in my tiny
rent-a-car to oklahoma city to see my
mother and she got into the car because
it was 110 degrees out and she said oh
here's one of my songs but you have to
sing along sing this part with me here's
your part yeah so so the two of you were
driving along to oklahoma city just in a
parked car it was very yeah she was
going to oklahoma i was just playing my
ukulele yeah
and you realized you started singing
together and you realized we've got
something yeah the minute we started
singing together we thought our voices
blended together really well and so we
started this band and it's been really
really fun now stephanie how does
someone pick up the ukulele i've never
understood that and i'm not putting the
ukulele down but it's an absurd
instrument and i'm putting it down
um my father i was playing a child's
guitar because i'm small
and my dad said that sounds horrible and
he stuck the ukulele in my hand and said
that could sound better and it's smaller
right so and it travels well you are i
have to say when i came to see the show
and i was looking at you on stage when i
first saw you i you're you're very young
looking and i mean i almost thought this
is a child who's who's
and you are not a child but is this a
problem for you in your life it happens
often last year i was stopped twice in
the airport by people who were concerned
that i was traveling alone
i did
i get that a lot too though
do you know where the security
checkpoint is and i'm like it's right
there and then oh you thought i didn't
know
like
but i'm wearing overalls so i guess
and you have a note pin to your shirt
that says please help me yeah
uh oh
now uh megan you have i just want to
mention make sure i get to this you have
a new movie that's coming out that
you're very proud of yeah this uh and
movie in indie movie that was um at
sundance and has done very well is
coming out on october 12th it's called
smashed stars aaron paul and mary
elizabeth winstead and um
nick offerman you might have heard of
him uh well i want to make sure you
mention this stephanie's new show how to
live with your parents for the rest of
your life debuts mid-season on abc and
tomorrow night nancy and beth are
playing at largo in los angeles that is
our show want to thank all my guests
nancy and beth thank you for doing this